مثل مئات اللبنانيين اتخذ ماهر قراره
بالاكتفاء بنايه طفلته الوحيده التي ولدت
قبل اشهر من دخول لبنان نفقه ازمته
الاقتصاديه
ازمه ادت الى وضع لبنان على خريطه ادنى
الدول العربيه بنسب الانجاب مع ارتفاع نسب
التضخم والغلاء المعيشي وتدني الرواتب
وانقطاع
الادويهن مثل ما هلا هي معيشه يعني حكون
مؤثر عليه عليها وعصاب اللي بده يجي وعلى
البيت واكل شيء حاضر
انت بدك بيبي تاني
[موسيقى]
بالعياده عم نلبسه بالدراسات صارت الناس
عندي اولويات مختلفه وهذا الشيء ايضا يشبه
دراسات اخرى غير مناطق بغير بلاد بحيث
الازمات
حددت الاولويات الحياتيه للناس
فيعني طاقه الجانب الاقتصادي والهم
المعيشي على الهم الصحي
معدلات الهجره ما يضع لبنان
بالنسبه غير بليد
والمعدل الخصوبه الخام يعني هو تقريبا 1
1.2 الي هو قديش احتمال العيله او المراه
تنجب خلال حياته الايجابيه يعني ولد ولد
فصل اثنين
مقارنه مع بلاد مثلا ثلاثه اثنين ثلاثه
خمسه
على حساب الاعمار الشابه اذا استمر تراجع
معدل الانجاب فان المجتمع سيصبح مجتمعا
كهلا مع مرور الوقت وبالتالي يخسر لبنان
راس مال بشريا لا طالما عول عليه للخروج
من ازماته